this would have been a talk that i gave
at a live show with an audience but it's
june 2020 as i record this so instead
i'm at home talking to my camera and
possibly my neighbors if they can hear
me and uh also cursing the drivers with
loud engines who seem intent on making
as much noise as possible directly
outside my flat today i asked 64 000
people about the children's rhyme jingle
bells batman smells and here is what i
found out
when i was a kid the next line of that
was robin flew away that was how the
song went in my school no more lines
turns out there are multiple competing
versions including the one that singer
and actor robert goulet sang on the
simpsons in december 1993 that version
goes jingle bells batman smells robin
laden egg
batmobile lost its wheel the joker got
away hey
thank you flew away versus laden egg two
different bird jokes and here's the
hypothesis that i want to test that the
simpsons measurably changed which
version of that song was popular the
kids who saw that episode either when it
first aired or in reruns either learned
it for the first time from there or it
replaced the version they knew
because according to various pop
histories that song was around four
decades before the simpsons it probably
started in california in the 60s
inspired by the adam west batman tv
series that it was spread by military
kids moving around america and the world
with their families
probably there are other jingle bells
parodies including some really genuinely
awful bigoted ones i am not considering
them i'm asking very specifically about
the one where batman smells and never
mind that it's entirely the wrong part
of the year it's 2020 time is
meaningless let's talk about jingle
bells in the middle of summer so i sent
out a survey first i asked each person
for two bits of information the year
they were born and the country that they
were in when they were eight i figured
eight years old is about the right time
for a kid to be endlessly singing this
at their friends in the playground now
if the person answering said they were
from the us or uk i asked for their zip
code or for the first part of their
postcode from when they were a kid that
meant i could very roughly put a pin in
a map for each of them and there are
those pins thank you very much to
everyone who responded and then i asked
two questions first what they call the
most basic playground chase game what
americans call tag and then second to
complete the song jingle bells batman
smells for both those questions i didn't
offer any suggestions i didn't want to
prompt with any words that might make
people go oh yeah sure that one i guess
they had to remember
which was probably a good idea but it
meant that sifting through this data was
a nightmare because give people a blank
text box and some of them will decide to
tell you their life story in it
in the analysis i only included
respondents who use the word robin in
their answer that's because for the
first couple of hours of that survey
being out i hadn't made it clear that
you could just leave that answer blank
if you didn't know so quite a lot of
people who didn't know the song
interpreted the question as
make up some lyrics of your own that's
my bad i suspect a few people back then
also googled the answer but i don't
think that'll affect the final results
all that much uh that also removed
people who were just quoting either
spongebob squarepants or madagascar
those versions were just invented by
scriptwriters and forced into kids heads
by marketing i don't want to count those
here
i was going to filter out anyone who
didn't use either flu or egg but it
turns out that more than a thousand
people know the next line of the song as
robin ran away i think if you don't have
a bird pun in that line you're um you're
missing out but who am i to judge i also
filtered anything that was obviously
spam or malicious when all that was said
and done once all that filtering was
finished i had answers from 42
886 people who knew some version of the
song with robin
here's the breakdown by year of birth
and by geography
now while i'm still counting answers
from earlier years i'm only going to
show graphs from 1973 and onwards
because those are the birth years where
i have more than 50 replies from both
the us and the uk the graphs get weird
before then and i think that's because
the number of people who put in false
birth years starts to have a really
significant effect i also can't collect
data from anyone born in 2007 or later
because the law is very strict on
collecting data from kids under 13. so
with all that in place i tracked
keywords for the various versions of the
song if you had a completely unique
version i wasn't going to count it
because it might contain personal
information uh shout out to the one
person who is insulting their siblings
in their answer at great lengths and
also explained all the jokes but if a
few people had roughly the same version
i did include a check for it so let's
talk about those many other variants i'm
not musical and frankly seeing a half
dozen ridiculous versions of jingle
bells sounds like something that will
very much come back to haunt me but i do
know someone who can perform these far
better than i can jack
jingle bells batman snails robin laden
egg
santa claus got a 44 and shot him in the
head hey barbie dolls barbie dolls tried
to save his life
teddy bear teddy bear stabbed him with a
knife that version was only sent in by a
few australians uh but also two people
from northwest washington dc so maybe
they were diplomatic or army kids no
idea on other versions of that it's
donald duck and mickey mouse doing the
stabbing because uh children are
monsters uh and on that note let's cover
the 39 people again from all over the
world who all share this second verse
dashing through the snow on a pair of
broken skis
or the hills we go
crashing into trees the snow is turning
red i think i might be dead i woke up in
the hospital
that was one of the less violent
versions of it one ends with a request
to be shot in the head now like i said i
did rule out any answer that didn't
include robin but i do want to highlight
just one international version of jingle
bells just to show this is not entirely
an english-speaking joke uh sweden has
many variations on this
[Music]
year's han stood and beyond mural
the color and particular private part of
the bear that's being painted uh appear
to change between people
now we get to the most common versions
one is almost exclusive to the uk and
new zealand because those are the
countries that use the word motorway for
big highways more than 2 000 people have
some variation on this robin flew away
uncle billy lost his willy on the
motorway
there are a long cast of characters all
of whom lost some usually intimate part
of their body or clothing on various
motorways that change depending on where
in the uk you are in south wales it's on
the m4 motorway uh in scotland the m9 uh
right 62 people almost all australians
said the last line of that should be
wonder woman
taa being a now defunct australian
airline uh however that is better than
the two scottish people who said it
should be mr blobby did a jobby on the
motorway
[Music]
the idea of 90s kids tv fever nightmare
mr blobby just defecating
i can't say that then there's this one
from 221 mostly british people where
after robin flew away
[Music]
and then from 23 british people mostly
80s
so he kids a milky way
kojak fictional tv detective with a
lollipop part of pop culture in the uk
in the 80s he lost his pants in the
middle of france and he found him in
bombay
again
british more than a hundred people
version after version after version of
the song came up as being popular over
here but not in the us or canada there
was only one significant variant that i
could find that was definitely north
america the batmobile lost its wheel
more than 1500 people know that version
including more than 15 of the canadians
who replied almost no one outside north
america has heard it there were a couple
of smaller american variations jingle
[Music]
90 people with a big cluster in the
pacific northwest the exact year changes
but almost everyone in that group agreed
that robin laid the gun
and the final north american variant is
in the joker saved the day
which just seems a bit half-assed
frankly like it got made up by a parent
trying to give the kids something more
wholesome to sing but it was only 35
people america seems to have way fewer
regional variations in the uk and i have
no idea why that doesn't just happen for
songs either in this book from 1959 the
law and language of school children iona
and peter opie conduct a survey of
dozens of schools in britain asking
about the words and rhymes they use it
is a famous piece of research but it's
also a catalogue on how children are
really cruel to each other there's a
whole chapter in here on nicknames and
epithets i'll just read from the table
of contents here they have a list of
names for spoiled sports sourpusses
spitfires clever dicks definitely fools
dumpsters copycats cribbers cheats swank
pots nosy parkers stair cats cowards
crybabies sneaks crawlers bullies
plus there's a whole section on torches
and hair pulling and a separate chapter
on physical appearance insults children
are monsters
anyway what this book also has are maps
which are the best known bit uh this old
copy here actually has its spine broken
on one of the map pages uh because
someone's photocopied it this map covers
truce terms the words that kids use to
say that they are temporarily out of the
game because they they've got stitch or
their timeless shoelaces in the uk those
words change not just in different parts
of the country but even from one town to
the next and that's why i asked about
the game that people call tag because if
you're american of course it's called
tag more than 96 percent of americans
and canadians replying said it was
called tag and almost everyone who
disagreed misidentified a different game
and wrote something like hide and seek
maybe because they didn't think i'd be
asking such a simple question in america
it's called tag
in britain
only 29 of people called it tag not only
are there different names but just like
the opis did for truce terms you can
draw a map of what tag is called around
the uk for some reason america tends to
be one massive homogeneous blob even for
games and songs that are made up more
recently whereas britain has loads of
variants which brings me finally to the
big question is it laid an egg or flew
away and did the simpsons change it
so first of all let's compare the basic
numbers now all i'm doing here is
showing the percentage of people who
said laden egg out of all the replies
who knew some version of the song and
yes you can see egg by far the most
popular 78 said it's egg so it seems
like there's a clear winner
until you break it down by country more
than 98 of americans said it was laid an
egg 98 you can't get 98 of americans to
agree on anything of course the simpsons
chose it only someone who grew up
outside the u.s would ever think that
sounds wrong but robin flew away is
clearly the british version but remember
the answers were also broken down by
year of birth for the u.s it's always a
very high percentage of course but if
the simpsons had an effect in the uk
then we would expect to see that 90s
kids which means people born from the
early 80s onwards they would be more
likely to know the egg version
and i wish i wish i wish i had a camera
on my face when i first saw that data i
could not ask for better proof of that
hypothesis can i 100 trace that back to
the simpsons
no of course not there could be some
other factor but the simpsons was one of
the most important pop culture shows in
the uk in the mid 90s a lot of folks
will have seen that episode and i cannot
think of any other reason for that
change and it also explains why the
change happens everywhere in the uk at
once this isn't a local version that's
spread outward from a single location
it's a version that appeared everywhere
probably because it was imposed by
television and as the simpsons drifts
into history as kids aren't watching it
anymore the british versions of the song
are reasserting themselves yes america
robin might well lay an egg for you but
over here he flies away
thank you jack thanks today's sponsor is
[Music]
you